new crews new heroes new villains and
new worlds these are just a few of the
things promised from the new Star Trek
TV series I'm Simon and this is your
intergalactic news update Star Trek is
heading back to TV screens next year and
the first teaser for the new show has
been released details on the upcoming
series are few but this short promo does
reveal a logo and suggests that it will
stand apart from the franchise's
previous series and movies earlier this
month it was reported that the show
would start production in the fall and
will shoot in Toronto Canada although
the title cast and broadcast date are
yet to be announced
former hannibal showrunner Brian fuller
will oversee the series alongside Alex
Kurtzman who co-wrote the last two movie
adventures while the first episode will
be broadcast on the CBS network Channel
all subsequent episodes will initially
screen on the company's all-access
digital subscription service making it
the first show to launch on a broadcast
network but air primarily on a VOD
service the last series in the franchise
was Star Trek Enterprise which ran for
four seasons between 2001 and 2005 the
teaser indicates a similar style to the
JJ Abrams movies and the graphic
certainly look more flashy than the
previous Star Trek series are you
excited for the new show or do you miss
Whoopi Goldberg giving wise counsel to
some butt-ugly Ferengi let me know in
the comments or come find me on Twitter
I'm at the jaqen all thanks for watching
and for your entertainment news keep it
GameSpot